talk about taxes because i know you're
big on taxes you got puerto rico
residents you're doing the whole thing
explain to everyone why you're so
focused on taxes
and trying to uh bring that tax rate as
low as possible so you can keep as much
income as possible
well i mean it's not what you make right
it's what you keep i mean that's we all
know that
and um you know it's an american's
patriotic duty
to minimize their taxes to pay the
lowest tax that they could legally pay
and that's not me that's the supreme
court said that so i'm
being a patriotic american and
personally i believe that any gov
money the government gets the government
wastes i think
money in my hands is is going to do
better than
money in the government hands and that
applies to every american keep the money
that you earn
but it's not just the income tax which i
think is so debilitating to the economy
it's the inflation tax we're talking
about inflation inflation is
a tax if you strip it of all the jargon
that's what it boils down to
because governments have two ways of
taking money from us
they can take it through taxes where
they take physically our money
or they can take our purchasing power
through inflation they just print money
and they spend that
but that means the value of our money
goes down because prices go up
and you know when joe biden campaigned
on not raising taxes
for anybody who uh earned less than 400
he's lying because the biggest tax
increases
are hitting the people who make less
than 400 000 because that's where
inflation does the most damage
it goes to the people who spend most of
their money
so if you're spending most of your money
and most of the lower income people
spend everything that they earn well
they're hit hardest by the inflation tax
and they're getting clobbered right now
but the reason that i want to avoid the
inflation tax
is because as an investor inflation can
create
phony capital gains so let's say i'm
right gold goes to 5 000
10 000 i have gold stocks let's say i
have
you know even 50 million of gold stocks
in that scenario
that turns into a billion dollars right
because the gold stocks go way up right
and now i sell and i cash out and the
government says oh you've got you know
this huge capital gains
well what at the same period of time my
cost of living has gone up five times
right so my gains are not really nearly
as big as as
the nominal numbers and it make it even
simpler
let's just say that you know my stocks
go up 10 times
but the cost of living goes up 10 times
so the price of everything i buy
is 10 times what it used to be and my
stocks go up 10 times
i haven't made any money i'm just even
if i sell my stocks i can still afford
to buy the same exact stuff
as i could buy before they 10x but then
if the government says oh you have a 50
capital gains tax now i'm i've lost half
my purchasing power
i didn't make any real capital gains i
had a phony capital gains
but the government was able to tax that
so by moving to puerto rico and this was
one of my primary motivating
factors they can never do that it
doesn't matter
how high prices go i don't have to pay a
capital gains tax because i'm locked at
zero
and that doesn't apply to just me it's
all the people that have moved here
to take advantage of the same deal